[Music]
welcome everyone left to talk of a day
of the conference advantages awake just
to be clear this is an introductory talk
it's really aimed at people who might be
kind of new to some of these ideas and I
won't be offended if you next bit and
you want to go to a different talk
that's fine we're going to be talking
about extracting topics from text and my
aim is to really kind of help us kind of
understand what the algorithms are doing
in an intuitive way rather than do a
session on linear algebra or anything
like that so if that's what you're
interested in we'll we'll dive in so and
we'll talk a little bit about text
mining and in particular topics what
they actually are
we'll will kind of cover some some ideas
around concepts and some maps that as I
said it's really to develop the
intuition and not to kind of you know do
a session on sort of linear algebra and
stuff like that probably I can't do it
and then we'll see the application later
applying it to some interesting data to
see how that works its usual to going to
do a slide on on who you are it's
usually very boring so that I make it
interesting this is that it's a picture
they took of me on reception and so if
you want to get in touch am I'm on
Twitter has post enterprise than a white
shows Elaine but what you do is you
can't change it I helped run the London
Python meetups a few interesting Python
in general come along to that it's once
a month I've just started another meetup
group on algorithmic art so if you're
interesting that come along and I've
written a little guide on your networks
which you may be interested in cool so
text mining so the world is full of text
it's everywhere people write blogs
people write books reviews as evidence
that police and other authorities
collect mostly texts
we all email each other there's positive
stuff we all like reports and they all
contain and news they all contain
interesting things and there's just
piles and piles of this stuff and it
would be really cool if we could in an
automated way understand what was in
that huge plethora of text and anyone
who could do this anyone can solve this
problem it's going to be you know pretty
powerful but that's that's the challenge
and it's it's it's a hard problem
because how we talk and write in English
and other human languages is messy
ambiguous our human languages aren't
constructed to be as precise as computer
programming languages and that's the
essential challenge of of text analytics
and text mining we're working with data
that doesn't really conform to precise
rules but there's still lots you can do
despite that challenge so just some fun
examples you know Maria saw the girl on
the manager of the telescope will
remember Uwe T there who's got the
telescope is a real headline scored
helps dog bite victim so the studies are
joke examples but they illustrate the
point that human language is is messy
ambiguous not precise what wasn't
designed for computation it's perhaps
the better kind of illustration of the
challenge so if I sort of had a
container with sort of three things in
there three numbers perhaps 3.1 3.2 and
11 117 point nine and I said to you you
know show me the two that are most
similar and most of you probably save
these two and if I said to you well why
you probably say well they're close in
terms of some some measure of distance
three point one is not at home from
three point two or perhaps you might say
3.2 is much further from from the the
bigger number so we can we can
understand that we're comfortable with
that but if I said can we do that with
some words you know which of these words
are most similar to each other
you would probably say Apple and Apple
and orange but if I said to you well why
you start to then think about some the
challenge in codifying in a computer
program your kind of thoughts around why
apple and orange are similar and it's
not easy but people have had kind of a
good attempts at trying to codify that
there's been lots of talk this this
conference already around you know where
company keeps so that's an example you
know the words that you might find
around orange are probably the words
that you find around Apple probably and
the words that around these two probably
aren't around the low cloud like that
gives you a need but if I sound kind of
unsure that's because it's not an exact
science so it's not an exact science you
know the data mining can feel a little
bit like alchemy can I reduce but having
said that you know despite the fact that
it's them a difficult non analytic
problem we can still do some really
useful things like we can search inside
text we can find words that are similar
by some definition of similar like the
one we've just talked about and that's
that's useful so here's a question just
to kind of get us thinking if I plotted
a word cloud which is showing the most
common words in a bunch of text I might
say - well what's what what's this text
about and you'd say yeah I think it's a
bunch of recipes maybe follow closest
Italian recipes and that's useful that's
an example of data mining and it's a
simple example
I know people take the mickey out of
word clouds but they're actually simple
and very effective you didn't have to
read the recipes to understand you can
have to read the text understand the
text was going was advanced recipes just
by looking at that so it is quite a
powerful technique that's an example of
text mining another example is you know
clustering together documents that are
similar and the measure of similarity
here is that they share common words it
might be a naive you know idea but it
works well enough so here's some
document
around the Iraq kind of report here some
Italian recipes is some Clinton emails
and here's some Shakespeare's text from
from Macbeth so that's that's useful
thing you can do I actually find it
quite interesting that if I plot more of
the stuff together you find that much
best related to Iraq maybe because
they're both about blood and killing and
stuff which is kind of interesting to
make you think well what Clinton got to
do with blood and killing and software
effect but interesting that recipes
aren't very connected to to those things
so those those kind of ideas are are
quite common now are they useful they're
really insightful as you've just seen
but clustering things together are is is
useful but it doesn't really answer one
question which is what are the key
themes or topics in a bunch of text and
that's what today's talk I hope
effective is about so what do I mean by
topics so if I had a bunch of texting I
may be able you know pile of papers with
some writing on it and I said to you
look at this here's some words what are
the topics in this pile of text and I've
color-coded them to make it make it
easier and you can look at that and say
actually yeah I can see there's two
topics there there's something around
cooking slice oven chop boil and maybe
there's another topic around vehicles
cars and that's exactly what we are want
to try and automate
we can separate those two topics out
that's what we want to do but how do we
do that that's the objective can we
automate that that's that's that's
really what we're trying to do and if we
could do it if you're really useful I
mean I've been lucky enough to work in
them some parts of the public sector
where you know we've had investigations
you know they'd be the hillsborough kind
of evidence displeasure or the inquiry
into s for child abuse the Iraq Carol
inquiry there's a lot of textual
evidence and it would help if we could
have
a computer help and guide us through all
that huge volume of of text I have to
say sadly historically hasn't been done
very well it's not being done very
automated I'm sure things will change
but that's you know if you work in
finance you and they're always sort of
litigating against each other and
producing sort of disclosures of
evidence and that can potentially be
interesting as well so let's just take a
step sideways a little bit now and try
and think about how we might solve that
problem as I say just a stress I'm not
going to go through sort of proofs of
mathematics or anything like that I'm
just trying to take little journey which
takes us from sort of simple ideas and
helps us to intuitively understand how
one of the methods works so we have text
but in order to work with it we have to
think of it as data so we have to
structure it in some way and most people
would say yeah we've got documents and
inside documents is text so make sense
yep and a very common way of encoding
that is to build a data structure matrix
which shows you which words are in which
documents and you may have come across
the term term document matrix and
there's lots of things you can do with
these which is why they're popular just
illustrate at the end that the word boil
appears in document two twice but
doesn't appear in this document so
missile number these things are quite
out later and I've color-coded these so
you can see the word slice appears quite
a lot in in that document we or appears
most in document one
so what we want to do with all that
information which is the words in the
documents and there are currencies in
some sense that's a lot of a lot of
information is its particular if you've
got realistic data with thousands of
words and lots of documents we have to
somehow reduce that into what we call
topics you know we don't want thousands
of topics we want something that says
actually we've taken all this data and
distilled it down to a few things a few
themes at a high level that's what we
want to do some of you may spark up and
say hey actually that sounds like
compression you know if you're familiar
with that side of computer science you
might say that's the task we're
compressing and representing this best
we can all that information with with a
lot less information yeah so what could
we do and we've got well the goal of
today so we could throw a few kind of
data points away at random it's not
where we could but I'm not sure that
would actually retain the most useful
information we can keep the biggest
numbers yeah that's probably getting
warmer but that's actually not too
dissimilar to what we did right at the
start with the word cloud you'll give
you the most frequently occurring words
but perhaps not the themes were getting
close maybe we can throw away some the
rows and columns of this thing so I've
said you know this is a naughty small
example but you know realistic datasets
would have I don't know 19,000 documents
with a vocabulary not of six words but
maybe 2,000 words that's a big matrix
maybe we chuck away some some of the
rows and columns and try and reduce that
exam approach maybe
so actually what we've just been doing
just throwing random ideas around so
instead of doing now let's try and be a
little more a little bit more systematic
and reasoned about how we do that so
take another side step away from above
them and say let's let's just start with
an idea a mathematical idea imagine we
have this this matrix is term document
matrix actually we want something
smaller so maybe I can break this down
into two pieces that are mathematically
related in some way and if that works
that would be nice wouldn't it because
then some information might be encoded
in here which which perhaps is useful
and tells me useful things about the big
matrix but it's distilled and small
weights it's much more easily understood
perhaps it's an idea but actually if you
remember your school maps multiplying
matrices has some rules so the number of
columns here and the number of rows here
have to match the number of columns rows
here which means these can't be any size
I can't can't just change this to any
size that doesn't work but let's not
give up let's let's extend the idea a
bit let's say we break it down to three
matrices and actually this looks more
promising because if we apply those
rules again about how the columns and
rows have to match off you find that
this number of columns here has to match
this one here the columns here the rows
here have to match the rows here and
this middle one can be any size that's
kind of magic that's really that's
really going to help us actually so if
we could break our term document matrix
down into three smaller ones Oh
similar sized ones or bigger ones the
fact that the middle matrix here could
be any size could be useful it might
mean that we could make this bigger and
smaller and by making it smaller we've
in some way
without unnecessary information and
still rebuild something that
approximates the the original data and
as it turns out there is a mathematical
approach that that does just that is
just that it's got horrible name from
other why mathematicians choose
unfriendly names is called a singular
value decomposition and all it does it
takes a matrix and breaks it down into
those three smaller matrices and you
know this is just like you know taking a
number 12 and chopping it up into 12 is
6 times 2 times 1
for example decomposition they love this
fancy words away and poison has has has
this method in fact if you google it
you'll find there's there's two or kind
of frustrating but the numpy seta
libraries has has the SPD and so does
Syfy and in fact the underlying core
code is the same but one subscribes a
few more options and you can you can
google that in fact I'm going to give
you links to notebooks online which
which illustrate how to how to do it so
you'll see a really simple example
that'll work through so you can have a
look at that afterwards
so just to going to repeat and re
underline what we've said we've said
we're taking some data this this is a
bitmap here which represents a face
we're decomposing kids into those three
things as I didn't talk about explaining
that a little bit yeah I should do that
so you know in simple terms there's some
nice features around this so this
mapping this breaking down just this
decomposition to three bits is kind of
unique I put a star there because it's
unique enough for us
I think mathematically it's not quite
but you can read more about it at this
link so it's good enough for us this
thing in the middle is really nice
because it's a diagonal matrix which
means it's zero everywhere except along
the diagonals and it's got a it's
ordered so the biggest number is in the
top left the numbers get smaller which
is really nice and neat for us it means
that if we choose to change its size we
we can chop out a small bit and we kind
of hope that means which if we if you
remove a small number maybe we're
chopping out the least significant bits
of information if you want to keep only
the most significant bits of information
maybe we just keep the biggest kind of
element of that of that matrix there are
some other bits like the fact that these
two are contain columns and rows which
are orthonormal don't worry about it too
much you'll see how that's useful later
so just to illustrate that point again
about reconstructing the data by
changing the size of this middle one
what if they change size means
discarding the some of the smaller
elements of it so if this is broken down
into these three if we say let's just
lose the smallest numbers and rebuild
that original data by multiplying those
three things again you get kind of a
good approximation and if I lose more of
those smaller element
you get a less good approximation but it
contains the main features so that's
that's kind of useful because what it's
saying to us is we can take a data and
we can have a smaller representation of
it while keeping the most important
features of that data the most the
features that give us give it's the main
shapes in that data so this is like
compression in fact some people have
done image compression as their ways of
doing it but it's an approach so let's
just talk a little bit more again
because this is talking meant to be
about intuition what's it doing see if I
said here's a bunch of data how would
you describe this data if you only had
one dimension to describe it but you'd
probably pick an axis along this
direction because it allows you to if
the direction of the most variance if I
said if I give you the luxury of another
dimension to describe the shape of the
data you might pick one that's kind of
along the other direction so with those
two kind of dimensions you've kind of
approximated the data well enough and
actually if you add more dimensions
maybe madam is coming out of the screen
at you you'd have another axis that
points towards you and you can keep
going on and refining how well you
describe the data but in point point is
you're you're early kind of selection of
dimensions describe the main feature so
with our very first description we
didn't point in this direction because
it wasn't the direction in which the
data varies most and that's really what
them what that decomposition is doing I
think it's interesting that these things
are in different directions in fact
they're also normal with when we do that
break down if you wanting a more kind of
mathematical kind of picture each of
those descriptions of the data are
actually the best fit
if you use a least squared distance that
you can have when you limit yourself to
one two three four five dimensions so
that's mathematically rigorous and you
can look that up if you want to so if I
looked at that middle Sigma matrix one
of the diagram numbers if I plotted them
and said actually the top left two
numbers were really large and the rest
are small well what does that tell me it
tells me that the first two dimensions
are the most significant in describing
the shape and the rest are just little
refinements or perhaps noise and this is
a useful check when you are decomposing
data to say actually you know how many
dimensions do I really need to describe
this data and I'll probably say two
maybe three but probably two is enough
air and that's a useful thing to be able
to check to see what those numbers
actually are in that descriptive matrix
the the the singular values in that
diagonal matrix but what they've got to
do a text which is what we're here for
so the the kind of assumption here is
better if we had a text data the
assumption is that each of these these
directions describes the topic that's
the underlying assumption I guess I have
to think a little bit about why that's a
good assumption but I think part of it
is that those topics are also normal
they're different they're not clusters
of similar things it's sort of saying
along this direction there is a there is
a theme of which the text either has a
lot of or little off
so let's see that applying to not an
image but the actual word term document
matrix so we're breaking it down and if
we take just these two multiplied
together what we doing if you remember
your school maps around multiplying
matrices what we've done if you look
across here it's remember it's the words
so the rows describe each words or what
the the occurrence of the word in the
document so row wise is a description of
the word and in this new view this new
kind of land where we've transformed
that data into the same thing happens
where we multiply rows of this u matrix
by kind of a selective element here it's
it's row like its word like that sounds
wooly and shaky so I'll talk a little
bit about that but you know if you
didn't want you're going to get into the
deep math or you could say the rows of
this thing are word like and the rows of
this thing I would like similarly comp
columns will be document like but I
didn't really believe it when I first
read about it so I spent a while try to
trying to kind of dig out some kind of
proof of it and I found them a
justification which convinced me this
actually is a reflection the fact that
this is all kind of a lot of text mining
is still a little bit kind of voodoo
none of it is going to mathematically
100% grounded in in axioms it's all a
little bit based on assumptions just
like a bag of word log that you've heard
a lot about so let's let's kind of them
if you're not interested in this but you
can close your eyes and take a rest is a
diversion but this is my justification
of why you times that middle matrix is a
new representation of of those words so
we know that the matrix the word doc you
made ryx can be broken down into you
Sigma and really that's convention if we
say that the if we multiply that thing
by its transpose its
so if you shift it along its diagonal
what you get is a word word correlation
matrix and if you write it as you'll see
why that's the case it's not hard to see
that if I expand this thing out and I
haven't got time to totally dig into it
but it's very simple maths here and I've
explained the algebra you end up with
these quantities being at the word word
correlation and because those are the
same you can think of these as word like
it's not mathematically the same as
saying that the word document matrix is
U times Sigma but they behave like that
and here's kind of a justification that
the best one I could find you can find a
better one let me know I've spent weeks
trying a five-digit certification anyway
back to back to text mining with topics
so what we've done let me supply it so
we anyone we looked at a really simple
set of documents with some six words and
we made the matrix with the word
frequencies what I've done here is
actually normalized so we've normalized
by document length because if you can
imagine long documents would unfairly
get prominence it'd be a lot of the same
word repeated so this is a common thing
to do and if we break that down a into
those three matrices and then multiply
these things together and if we only
keep the top two values this is what we
end up with and these are the topics so
the first topic is
made up of some combination of slice
oven and boiled and the second topic is
made up of some combination of real
seasoned engine that's right that set of
documents were about two different
themes and this is what they are
the first topic has nothing to do with
wheel seat or engine the second topic is
nothing to do with slice oven and boy it
separated those out that's kind of nice
you can and you can look at the
notebooks which are online to going to
explore yourself and have a play let's
apply to bigger data because that was a
small Nordy example so you know in 2012
government released form 50,000 pages of
evidence around the Hillsborough
disaster is from age five organizations
is that 19,000 text files and if we
apply kind of a pipeline which you'll be
familiar with a lot of this thing we
take the original text we clean it a
little bit by you know removing some of
these multiple white spaces we might
keep only the alphanumeric characters
might lowercase it you know the standard
things you'll do to clean up textual
data and then we make the matrix in fact
I'm done something a little bit more
sophisticated than the word count or the
frequency we've applied the tf-idf which
you've heard about in some of the other
talks here it's simply saying that words
that appear in every document like it
was there aren't actually that
interesting so you give prominence to
words that appear a lot in some
documents are penalized on mister appear
everywhere so term frequency boosts at
school but inverse document frequency
penalizes it so the word app will appear
everywhere again you can read more about
it um with this link online and then we
do the decomposition of that matrix my
computer wasn't powerful enough to
crunch through all of that so in the end
I applied another filter which was just
keep English words which which might
lose some interesting words and this is
the spectrum is aware of that middle
matrix which gives you an indication of
well one of the most important
dimensions this is a full block it's a
very long tail but you can see that
there's maybe one two three four four
maybe five dominant topics and here is
what they are and if I look at them well
what do I see I see well from the words
are right you know talking about police
the material the ground and the actions
the people something around sort of some
of the inquires that happened afterwards
like the Taylor inquiry but if I'm
honest and didn't wear that well yeah
okay so back to the drawing board I'm a
while-- of this Jeff and want to do this
exactly I saw was gonna say Doctor Who
that's because a lot of the original
material was photocopies or photocopies
of handwritten notes scanned then ocr'd
and the extracted text looks like this
so you can understand why naively
applying some cool library function
doesn't give you great results so this
is just I put this in here just to
remind us that data looking at your data
explore and get front is really
important actually and actually given
that a lot of data looks like this junk
it's surprising that it's kind of done
that well let's let's try it on a
cleaner dataset so the iraq report was
typed into a word processor I imagine
rather than sort of bits of paper and
sort of many years ago and this thing's
got 2.7 million words by the way I'm one
of those people that loves to really
understand how these cool algorithms
work so all this stuff I've done is
total written from scratch and you'll
find that the github code
super simple so I've avoided using all
the useful and cool libraries that are
out there they do a much better job like
Jen Sam and so on because I think it's a
useful thing to do too if you really
understand how something works you have
try and recreate it yourself so this
thing gives me a spectrum like this
which tells me there's some really
significant topics in there and there's
a bit of a bit of a tail so it's
probably around 1 2 3 4 maybe maybe 10
if I'm being generous so let's look at
the ten most significant topics that's
probably too small to read so I can
summarize those let's look at this one
so this one has words like treaty
Britain Ottoman Mesopotamia resolution
so it's kind of like the history of the
Iraq kind of scenario that some of the
treaties on the kind of historical kind
of demarcations let's look at another
one the veterans mental medical inquest
health reservist coroner's witness so
that tells you that maybe there's a
topic in that text around you know the
veterans and their kind of health after
the event and how they were perhaps
treated well or not well there's an
interesting one on the top top right
there telegrams documents Spelling's
redactions egrants transcripts so that
seems to be about messaging the top left
one is running out I'm on I okay the
point is that this works much better and
you use interesting that you can get out
some distinct topics from that text and
the magic is I didn't read the text so
as a tool for investigating a bunch of
evidence or a bunch of texts this idea
extracting topics is really really handy
I didn't have to read any of that text
and I probably would if I was a
researcher you know digging to specific
areas of it but this gives me a head
start in what are the key topics within
a bed and a part of text
so I hope that I've given you some
intuition around how topic extraction
can work I hope I've inspired maybe some
of you to go on and kind of look again
afresh at some of the proper libraries
like Jensen that maybe kind of rethink
again about some of the assumptions that
underlie those those libraries so I
think you know it will be silly to just
apply some of these cool library
functions to bunch of text and not
really understand what the one of the
limits of that approach that would be
perhaps and wide if you want to find out
more there's a blog these slides there's
stuff on github and if you want to
message me I'm on Twitter thank you very
much yeah oh yeah so it was just for me
to say that the green ones were
particularly well represented and some
of the red ones were kind of maybe not
so well represented the one so clear is
just a visual aid for myself and I did a
question mark here say I couldn't read
Ian's and what they're talking is about
yeah so the question was what are these
colors mean of coded these of color
these as green and red it was just for
me to say to myself that these are the
topics that were really clear from the
topic distraction and the ones that I've
colored red when I looked at them there
were medium clear and there's just one
that really wasn't clear at all to me so
I think that's a really good question
it's a difficult one because what you're
trying to your topics like if you look
like to start with the recipes cooking
and and traffic you know automobiles
those words weren't actually in the text
so the recipes that didn't actually have
the word cooking or the word recipe so
your question is how do we name a
so quick and potentially the name
doesn't even occur that's a that's an
interesting question I don't know the
answer to that if someone can do that
they'll be brilliant and maybe some of
these ideas around using some of the
vector models that people are built to
say you know maybe there's some sim
similarly distant word that's similar to
all the other words in a in the
description of topic maybe that's an
approach I'm really explored it but it's
a good question
this gives you the content of a topic as
a linear combination of all those words
but it doesn't give you the actual name
of the topic but that might be maybe a
next step to kind of explore a good
question thank you go for it yeah go up
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is this is
this is in quests that says in quest so
singular and plural and that's because
in my pipeline I didn't do what some
people do which is stemming so if you're
a practitioner of text mining in this is
the steps of cleaning up your text and
preparing it
you might stem it or remove plurals of
words you might do that so your next
part of your question was is any way of
stopping you from overly boosting that I
can only think of them no can't think of
a great way of doing that I guess if a
word appears twice but once in plural
maybe deserves to be more prominent
because it has appeared twice consequent
immediate answer that but the reason
that there is I didn't do the stemming
or the removal of plurals and if I was
doing this more seriously then that will
be part of my preparation steps
[Applause]
[Music]